j'aurais écrit constamment la même chose
ça sert à rien de se questionner sur ce
qui aurait pu être rien ne compte en ce
monde si tu es ça n'y est pas
j'espère que ça avance avec le nouveau
livre tout le monde meurt d'envie de le
voir et j'ai bien peur de ne pas pouvoir
les faire patienter bien longtemps tu
peux pas forcer l'inspiration je le peux
quand je te donne un quart de million en
avant
j'ai vu Nathalie pendant les fêtes elle
a demandé tes nouvelles elle a déménagé
à Lisbonne
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu viens
maman
[Musique]
j'aimerais tellement revenir en arrière
je suis passé à autre chose il faudrait
que tu fasses au temps
je sais qui tu es si c'était que moi tu
crèverais en prison
j'ai tellement peur d'échouer que je
finis par tout détruire autour de moi
sans cesse dans ma vie il y aurait pas
eu de livre mais s'il y avait pas eu de
livre elle serait toujours là je suis
pas prêt à tourner la page tu peux pas
te mettre à parler de nous comme ça je
veux même pas imaginer vivre un seul
moment sur terre sans toi mes côtés
tu joues tant je reste avec ma patience
[Musique]
sans toi
je suis rien
je suis démoli perdu et seul
c'est facile de croire que notre
capacité d'aimer est limitée surtout
quand on a le cœur brisé mais crois-le
ou non avec le temps tu vas guérir
on ne sait jamais la chance qu'on a de
passer sa vie avec son âme sœur
jusqu'à ce qu'on doit vivre sans elle
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]